hello sir you all right yeah I'm officer
Warren from Police Department can you go
and stay up for me please yeah do you
have a registration for your bike love
to uh actually no uh I don't you don't
uh so I bought this bike
yesterday from where uh so it's from
it's a private dealer uh so it's a guy
uhhuh and I don't have his is uh
personal information are you injured no
okay what
happened I don't know man I just
uh really wanted to ride home tonight
and it's my new bike and uh yeah I uh
really wanted right mov did you hit
something or did you just dump it or
what yeah I just like you know pretty
fucking hit something yeah what' you hit
dumped it so you just dumped it yeah
okay wasn't
ready do you have your ID
yeah so here's my debit card okay I
don't want that
okay
sorry man you all right yeah here's my
idea all
right Mr have you had anything to drink
tonight no nothing at all no where you
coming
from uh just my friend's place where's
that
at West champag West West orbana
actually West orbana yeah West orbana
Okay so so near here or far from here
far from here Dro your
money barely a
money give me a favor breathe on me real
quick no Breathe on Me breathe out
breathe out blow
out
okay seea anything to drink no you said
you're coming from a friend's house yeah
where you going home home where's home
at home I'm trust man if you want to
follow me there like you can you can do
that what's your highest level of
Education uh College probably I don't
know man did you go to college no I'm a
smart man uh yes so you graduated high
school yeah okay but you never went to
college yeah uh
uh yeah I went to college yeah okay all
right when's the last time you had
something to
eat
uh shit man I don't know 4 hours ago
four hour would you have to
eat goes cheese okay all right so it's
safe to assume you know all your letters
of the alphabet yeah okay could you
recite the alphabet starting with the
letter e and finishing with the letter P
without singing e to p o e to P yeah e
to P without
singing l m n p u RX v u YZ oh shit
man it's okay take your time I got all
that e to
p l
MN op p
e
we can move on to something different
man all right do you know all your
numbers from Z to 100 you know all your
numbers I I can do it in Spanish man
okay all right uh in English could you
count backwards for me from 71 down to
49 71 70 uh 71 70 70 uh
70 69 68 67
60 60
uh 67 66 65 64 63 63 62 61
69 60
61 60
69 68 oh you know okay okay all right
thank you that's all right I appreciate
it okay you sure you haven't had
anything to drink yeah okay pretty sure
pretty sure huh okay all right you
willing to do some peel sobriety tests
for me make sure you're okay to ride
this
song No you don't want to do any f for
tense why
not come on man said you have anything
to drink
right dude are you going to be cool with
me or not I'm being very cool with
you
no I'm just going to I'm just going to
go home okay well you can't go home are
you sure I'm sure yeah are you willing
to do the skri
test fuck you guys so that's a no no
that's no no I'll do it oh okay I mean
I'll do it I'm just saying fuck you guys
okay well that's fine you can say that
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
I'm going to check your eyes Okay do you
wear contacts or glasses
okay do you have any pet
injuries
no I'm just really mad
okay so you don't have any type of head
injuries or anything like that no okay
all right okay so I got to read you
these don't get so close to
me I'm going to read these these
instructions to you for B them don't get
so to me fuck off man don't push me man
well I just I just I'm not D I'm not I'm
not getting that close to you man I'm
not getting that close to you man you're
getting closer than I want you to be no
no don't be don't be a bitch baby don't
be a bitch okay don't be a bitch all
right I'm going to read these
instructions to you okay dude fucking
fuck off
man fuck
off fuck off
baby dude come on
man no don't be dude don't be so fucking
fuck off
man what did I do do to you what did I
do to you you're a little out of control
are you serious yeah yeah did I really
fucking threaten you did you feel
threaten I asked you several times to
you feel threaten me did you feel
threatened did you feel threatened I
feel fine oh yeah I know you do I know
you feel
fine you never felt threatened
man do you want to fight all right man
I'm glad that you fucking had your f
fucking Power Trip man I'm glad you had
it that's
cool no pick it up man pick it up he's
picking it up that's why I him got he's
already what what's in there what's in
my wallet man what's in my wallet I
dropped your pizza card oh shit oh my
God my fucking shit my pizza card oh my
God
oh don't
worry Yep this start talk to you guys
already he just got our information he
just got your okay how did you guys come
up on gentlemen so we were going up to
uh to cover ran tool and his bike was
laid down here and there was the
gentleman in the black car left um and a
cop no it was a bystander and so the
bystander was kind of looking at me and
so we initially thought this guy hit him
but he this guy came up to me and said
he just laid his bike down and stood up
got over here um and then by the time
the guy on the bike was walking back
over here we could tell he was hammered
so um called it in and then he pretty
much ateed over his bike and then looked
at us and was like yeah I'm absolutely
hammered so he said that yeah he did
yeah multiple times he said I'm Hammer
yeah multiple times yeah all right
okay Tim hey what's your name Tim Scott
officer Warren Warren all right cool
come on H up no what's your first name
man officer oh officer mhm all
right this way we're going to go in this
door right here J
St
no I'm
good oh here this way no I'm good let's
go no I'm good hey do
good see that yellow chair right here
I'm going have you take a seat right
here for me please let see thank you I'm
really
sorry you're sorry yeah that's okay I
appreciate you saying you're sorry I'm
good to go home though
11:24
is the current
time
yeah yeah can you stand up and give me a
breath
sample got your gloves on yeah all right
what do what do I actually have to do
for you
man okay may you stand up for me please
what do I actually have to do for you
just blow into this mouth P when I tell
you
too that's
all you're not going to like do anything
after that no we'll see what happens
come on stand up all right so what I
going to have you do is just take a long
deep breath okay and then blow out
really long strong steady blow like
you're blowing up a balloon like
this I'm just going to keep blowing like
that until I tell you to stop okay all
right okay all right take a deep breath
use your diaphragm suck in open your
mouth and blow push push push harder
harder push keep pushing keep pushing
keep pushing you're almost there you got
to keep going that's not long enough you
got to blow a little longer than that
until It Gos quick breathing low push
push push push you're not pushing at all
I'm doing my best man dude if you don't
provide this bre sample on my market is
a refusal and you're automatic going to
get your life and suspended for a year
okay so you get one more
opportunity take a deep
breath with me I'm trying to I'm trying
to all right I need you to take a nice
deep breath and blow hard yeah I will
so dude Tom me trust me man I will blow
hard Mo if you don't if you don't
provide a good sample then it's going to
get suspended for a year please tell me
it's in my in my take take a deep breath
I will I right now right now no trust me
I will I'll I'll give you good I'll give
you a good example I don't need I need
you to take take a nice deep breath and
blow into this tube okay breathe in fuck
you man you're not promising me anything
I'm not promising you anything that's
right I'm not but I'm saying if you
refuse to provide this breath sample
your license is automatically suspended
for a year all right if you blow and
it's over. away it's only 6 months okay
that's the difference I just you're help
me out man I'm trying to but you got to
help yourself okay you have to help me
help me take breath I just really wish
you had someone deep breath all right
do
blow push I don't like you dude okay all
right you can sit
[Music]
down a
SE you're pushing me down man well
you're not doing what I ask you to do
you push me down man well I asked you
several times I'm only going to ask you
a couple times I'm just going to make
you do it now you push me down
motherfucker stay in
the come on man stay in the chair come
on what do you think you're going to do
right now you push me
down that's right here
there don't be mean man man take a deep
breaths please don't be mean man that's
all I'm
asking do I really feel like I'm trying
to like you know cause you
problems does it feel like that way man
does it feel like I'm trying to cause
you
problems it's like you're being a little
uncooperative ooh okay all right what's
your name Warren
Warren
o meet me up
Warren my
place so what are you doing
Warren what you write num Warren that
you refuse to provide a breath sample
I thought I did that I told you I
thought I did that you did not did oh
I'm pretty sure I did that man it was no
I did
that didn't I do that you started to but
you didn't finish
it oh come on
man what you come
on what you mean come on thought I
didn't blow you had to
Blow instead of not so sit down so what
do we all right so so let's do that
let's do that let's let's do uh let's do
your fucking uh let's do your blow here
what's what's going on now let's do your
below all blow all blow let's let's uh
that time has passed oh it's pass
man let's let's mark that down mark it
down mark it down I'm marking it down
right now marking it down yeah all right
Mr Nicks I'm going to read you your
rights and ask you some questions okay
yeah sure fucking bring it on man all
right you have the right to remain
silent anything you say can be used
against you in a court of law or other
proceedings you have the right
toy any questions if you cannot afford
an attorney one will be appointed for if
you wish do you understand the rights I
provided you oh yeah they
better what time is it
now great question man let me check my
phone do you have any idea what time it
is right now uh yeah let me check my
phone
motherfucker what is the date don't Are
you seriously answering that question
right now I'm asking that question come
back if I want
to can I please can I I ask you these
questions on this box okay yeah let me
fuck what is the date yeah let me check
my fucking date man what day of the week
is it hold on
motherfucker when did you last eat shut
the fuck up what did you eat fuck off
okay
I'm trying to check my fucking
watch I'm asking you off the top of your
head I'm trying to check my fucking
watch without checking your watch what
time is it dude without checking your
watch just yes I don't know fucking
12:17
okay what were you doing the last 3
hours hanging out having a great time
okay have you been drinking
no where were you hanging out
time time so you weren't drinking at all
no no so it be pointless to ask me when
you started and stopped drinking that
would that would be very pointless were
you operating a vehicle SL motorcycle
immediately prior to police contact no
do you believe your consumption of
alcoholic beverages today has impaired
your driving in any manner no we're
going to go to the hospital and get a
clearance to the jail because you're
involved in a motor vehicle accident
okay shouldn't take too long
hopefully be real quick I don't know
sounds good you seem
really
not that uh that ensured that we should
go to like you know a hospital yeah well
you have to when you're involved in an
accident no we will though yeah we will
it's cool no it is cool yeah super cool
yeah so are you going to like you know
do this that way okay oh watch
that
all right watch your head man when you
sit down are you going to when you sit
down I don't want you buk your head no
I'm you going to do this do what you
going to take my cups off or not right
now going to have your cups in the car
man have a seat are you sure I'm sure
are you sure come positive you can take
come sit down are you sure your head
come on are you sure here sit back
you're like you're going going too far
you're going too far north yeah you know
a different you know a different way to
get to the hospital turn right turn
right get your right dude get in the
right lane get in your right lane
fucking right dude get in the right
fucking Lane dipshit Michael relax man I
know where the hospital is okay I've
been there a time or two I mean you're
fucking going the wrong way though I am
not it's right there you look you see it
right there it says coral on the side of
that big building right up
there where are you actually you to go
though to the
hospital good like
it all right we're going to hop out here
and step inside for a few minutes you
know you're not letting me off here I'm
not letting you off here we're just
getting a clearance to the jail come on
now oh
okay so what do I have to do just uh
just keep cooperating and just answer
their questions the nurse going to ask
you some questions and whatnot okay
that's it that's it they're going to
make sure that you're okay and then
we'll go to the jail and and then you
come out of those guns oh we get to the
gym you going make sure I'm